here now with more it's Texas Senator
Ted Cruz is with US senator great to
have you thank you for joining us
Sean great to be with you thank you for
having me we appreciate it Senator do
you want to weigh in at all I know
you're you know Alan dershowitz says you
were one of his best students do you
want to weigh in at all on these
allegations I mean I look at this letter
from grafley and comer yeah and they're
saying that they believe the doj and the
FBI possess an unclassified FD 1023 that
describes an alleged criminal scheme
involving then Vice President Biden and
a foreign National relating to the
exchange of money for a policy decision
uh that would be a high crime and
misdemeanor Senator it it absolutely
would in fact it doesn't have to be a
high crime or misdemeanor because the
Constitution specifies that impeachment
lies for treason bribery or other high
crimes or misdemeanors bribery is
explicitly noted in the Constitution and
and I got to say the evidence not only
against Hunter Biden but the evidence
against Joe Biden being complicit and
profiting from this corruption is
growing and growing and growing every
week on my podcast I've verdict with Ted
Cruz I've walked listeners through the
detailed evidence that's growing and
here's the tell look I I think the Biden
Department of Justice is going to end up
indicting Hunter
but if they indict him just for the gun
crime or just for a tax crime
they're going to try to explain it as
he's a he's a troubled soul he's got
substance abuse issues but look how fair
we are and now we can go Target Donald
Trump which is what the Biden Department
of Justice really wants to do that will
be the tell if they focus on individual
crimes to Hunter and they seal off what
makes this a matter of public concern
which is the connection to Joe Biden the
millions Hunter made selling access to
Daddy when he was vice president he made
it from barisma the Ukrainian natural
gas company he made it from communist
China 10 for the big guy and Merrick
Garland Biden's attorney general does
not want to get near the growing and
growing evidence of corruption going
straight to the president of the United
States Senator we're near the end of
title 42. we see what's happening in El
Paso in Texas in your home state how bad
is it going to get and by the way our
thoughts and prayers for the families uh
five families murdered in Cold Blood
including an eight-year-old kid uh thank
God we got that guy last night
well look it is it is horrific that the
the crisis at our Southern border is the
worst in history we've had over six
million people cross illegally under Joe
Biden this is deliberate it is their
intended effect and next week they're
going to lift title 42 which means the
numbers will go up Joe Biden and Kamala
Harris and the Senate Democrats they
want 6 million to become 10 million to
become 12 million to become 15 million
and they don't care about the body bags
that are piling up you you noted the
horror that played out in Cleveland
Texas this monster murdered five people
in Cold Blood shot an eight-year-old
child he was an illegal alien he'd been
deported four times and yet under the
Biden open borders policies he was
allowed to stay ice didn't find him they
didn't Deport him they didn't send him
away the Democrats blocked Kate's law
which I wrote which would lock up
aggregate aggravated felons if this
monster had been in jail
five people would still be alive that
eight-year-old child would still be
alive and yet none of the Democrats want
to change course they want more of the
same more death and suffering and Chaos
it it is the president get away with
aiding and abetting in the law breaking
because that's exactly what he's doing
well it's very simple number one he flat
out lies about it he sends out Kareem
Jean-Pierre who says illegal immigration
has decreased 90 percent under this
Administration that's a flat out lie
number two the corporate media is
utterly corrupt so they don't they don't
cover it that's why what you do Sean is
so important shining a light on on the
humanitarian catastrophe playing out
right now in our Southern border and
does everyone agree we need Ted Cruz
reelected
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else